Okay Michael, so, let me see if I can convince
you that we actually have some way of actually estimating
these distributions. So, all I've written up here is the
chain rule version of a joint probability distribution, okay? But just
to be clear, what these subscripts mean here, every x
that we have is made up of a set of features.
So, there's, let's just say there is N of these
features. And so really, X is a vector. There's feature one.
There's feature two. There's feature three, dot, dot,
dot. All the way up to feature N. Okay?
>> Sure.
>> What I really want to know for my piece of theta and I'm
going to drop the theta's here for the
purpose of just describing this generic distribution.
Is I want to say, well the probability of me seeing all of the
features yeah, all of the features of some particular example is just the joint
distribution over all of those features. Now of course,
we could just estimate this, but that's going to be hard.
>> Why's it going to be hard? Because.
>> Well, the first distribution is conditioned on a lot
of things, so it's an exponential sized conditional probability table.
>> Exactly, so this is exponential table and if
it's an exponential table then we need to have
an enormous amount of data in order to estimate
it well and this is sort of the fundamental problem.
But, we have addressed this in earlier lectures, earlier lessons Michael.
>> In the inference lecture maybe?
>> Yes, in the inference lecture.
>> Whew.
>> Where we can try to estimate this incredibly painful joint
distribution by making some assumptions about
conditional independence, and in particular I'm
going to make, one kind of assumption. And that is, that we
only care about what's called Dependency Trees. Okay, so what's a dependency
tree Michael? Do you remember?
>> No I have absolutely no idea, I
don't think I've ever heard of such a thing.
>> So the Dependency Tree is a special
case of a Bayesian network, where the network
itself is a tree. That is, every node,
every variable in the tree, has exactly one parent.
>> I see. So sometimes in Bayesian networks, they
talk about polytrees. Polytrees just mean that if you
ignore the direction of the edges, you have a
tree. But you're actually talking about the, the edges have
to go in a particular direction. Everybody's got one parent.
>> Right, exactly right. And in, and in, so,
you should see these as a directed graph, although I
almost never draw them that way. Because, you know, it's
sort of obvious by looking at it. That this is
the root of the tree. So all we have here
now is a tree. Every node has one parent, and
what does that mean? That means that every node, every
random variable, depends on exactly one other random variable. Yeah.
>> So
we can rewrite this joint distribution here now as a
product over each of the features depending upon only its parent.
>> I see. So the first capital pi there means
product. And the second lower case pi there means parent.
>> Exactly. So when I compare
this representation of a distribution, dependency to
representation versus the full joint. What nice properties do I get from doing
it this way versus doing it that way? Well the, I guess the main positive is
that you're only ever conditioned on, well it's
gotta be at most one, right? Not exactly one?
>> Right. At most one, so, so in fact you, you picked up on
a nice rotational thing here. The parent of the tree, the root of the tree
doesn't actually have a parent. So just
assume that in this case Pi returns itself
or something and so it's the unconditional
distribution. And that could happen at any time.
>> Got, gotcha, alright, yeah and so, like if
nobody has any parents, then that's the same as Naive
Bayes, but here it can happen with those one parents.
>> No.
>> No?
>> Naive Bayes has one, exactly one, everyone
has one parent and it's exactly the same one.
>> Oh, right, good point.
>> So, if everyone has no parents, then you're saying that
all of the features are in fact, independent of one another.
>> Gotcha. Okay. Alright. But the, but that's not what you
asked. You asked comparing that probability distribution to the full joint,
the main thing is that you're, no ones ever conditioned on more than
one, other feature and therefore the
conditional probability tables stay very, very small.
>> Right. In fact do you, how small do they stay?
>> Well it depends on how big this, are
there, are there binary features that we're talking about?
>> Yeah let's say they're binary. So
then it's like two numbers. Right. It's like
you're probability when your parent is true
and your probability when your parent is false.
>> Well that's each table. But what about representing the entire thing?
>> So it's going
to be linear in the size of the number of variables or.
>> Right.
>> Features.
>> Right and the number, the amount of the data that you
need is going to be fundamentally. In order to get this tape, in
order to get this tree, it's going to turn out that you only
need to keep track of quadratic set of numbers, quadratic in the number.
>> We're not going to be given that
tree, we're going to have to figure that out?
>> Well, remember, one of the steps in
the algorithm is you have to estimate the distribution.
>> So we're going to have to figure out, of all
the trees that I might have, which is the best tree?
>> Yeah, that' doesn't exactly follow from the algorithm
sketch because you could also say well, then you need
to figure out that a tree is the right
thing at all instead of something else like a box.
>> Oh, that's fair, but what we're going to
do is were just going to assume that
we're going to do the dependency trees, now why
are we doing this? Were actually doing this for
a couple of reasons Michael, your, your points
pretty your points well taken. Dependency trees have
this nice feature that they actually let you
represent relationships. The point is that you're actually able
to represent relationships between variables. Which in this case are sort
of features in our space. But you don't have to worry about
too many of them, and the only question here then is how
many relationships do you want, what kind, which of all the possible
relationships you could have where you only are related to one
other thing, do you want to have. Well, in some sense a
dependency tree since you can depend on at most only one other
thing, is the simplest set of relationships you can keep track of.
The next simplest would be, as you point out, not having any
parents at all. In which case, you would be estimating simply this.
>> Yeah, I wouldn't say that the
next simplest. That's even simpler. But it doesn't,
doesn't allow any of the inter-relationships. Any
of the co-variants essentially information to be captured.
>> No, that's fair, that's a fair point. So, we could have started with
something like this except here you must
you you're forced to ignore all relationships because
you're treating everything as independent. And we don't believe that things
are independent or at least we think there a possibility there's some
dependence. And so by allowing at most that you're connected to
one other parent that's sort of the least committed to the idea
you could still be while still allowing you to capture these
relationships. So that's the basic idea. Now I want to be, I
want to be strict here that the mimic algorithm or just this
whole notion of representing probability distributions
does not depend upon dependency trees.
We're going to use dependency trees here because you have
to make some decision about how to represent the
probability distributions, and this is kind of the easiest
thing to do that still allows you to capture relationships.
>> I buy that.
>> Okay and one other thing worth noting is I you'll I hope
you'll see this is a couple of slides if you don't see it
immediately, is that at the very least this will allow us to capture
the same kind of relationships that we
get from cross over in genetic algorithms.
>> Huh?
>> And that was a bit of the, the inspiration
for this. That cross-over is representing
structure. In this case structure that's
measured by locality, and this is kind of the general form of that.
>> So you are saying if there is some locality, then whatever,
however we're going to learn the dependency tree from the samples is going to
be able to capture that. And therefore, it will kind of wrap
its head around the same kind of information that that cross over's exploiting.
>> That's exactly right,
and in fact, as we'll see in one of the examples
that I'll give you in a moment, that it can do
better than that because it doesn't actually require locality the way
that crossover does. There's one other thing that's worth mentioning here
about this distribution and why it's nice. It captures relationships. But
the second thing is, something that you, you sort of alluded
to earlier is that, it's very easy to sample from. Right?
So given a dependency tree where each one of these features,
each one of these nodes, represents a feature, it
is very simple, very easy to generate samples consistent with
it. Right? You just start at the root, generate
a sample, unconditional sample according to whatever the distribution is
and then you go through the parents and you
do the same thing. So it's exactly a topological sort
and in trees topological sorting is very easy and
this is in fact, linear in the number of features.
>> Right. I get that and it is
exactly an instance of what we talked about when
we did Bayesian inference The thing that is new is
how do we figure out dependency tree from the sample.
>> Exactly, that's what we're going to
do next and that's going to involves math.